I didn't, I didn't over the carpet? No? You can tell I'm a man. I didn't over the fucking carpet, shit.
Shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh.
It's okay, it's okay, it's okay, it's okay, it's okay, it's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
I didn't over the carpet, oh shit, wait, no, hold on, let's not wipe fucking, hold on, I need you to shut up.
Okay, this is all contestant. Replay, hi, like it's me.
Look, I'm moving and stuff, I'm real.
Okay, so this is the week schedule. We have BioShock to spread over two days, because I like being spread, you know what I'm saying?
And then I have a collab on Catarina's channel after Catarina and I though, but she's idle until November, so it's not wrong.
And then I have ASMR on a mannequin and camera, my usual strength down here.
And then I have a members watch launch ring.
And then you're turning me into a weeb, we're gonna do, you're gonna, we're gonna do a series of you turning me into a weeb, and we're watching Sugar Happy Life.
And then we're gonna turn it, boy robs the bank.
And then I'm doing Jane together with Amy, Actay, and Miss Ma.
And then we'll do a members ASMR afterwards.
And then we're doing a hand cam pop and cooking stream, and Kimberly and Vigor, welcome to join.
And then we're just gonna, I don't know the words, because I need to make sure I've got them right.
Okay, if that seems correct.
Oh god, you can see the webcam shadow.
No, this looks so scant.
You can see the webcam shadow is so clear.
Oh no.
I don't think I can do anything about that.
I don't think I can do anything about the webcam shadow.
I think I'm gonna rank that.
Alpha takes a lot.
Band-aid woman and Gimli Gobi.
She's really good at scratching her hand.
Hold on.
Excuse me woman, just to ruin the immersion.
Oh fuck, the board isn't even there.
Sorry, my PowerPoint is behind the piece here.
I don't even know very much.
Wait, what did you see?
What did I just show?
Why is everyone saying dumpy sported?
Did you not just see the back of my head?
Hold on, fuck the ASMR.
Was that not just the back of my head?
Okay, I went blurry.
Thank fucking god, because I'm in a thong and nothing else.
Okay, let's sit back down again.
Panic over.
Let's sit back down again.
I mean, this is probably the best I can do.
Holy dumpy.
This is the best I can do for the latex.
My fucking ring line.
ASMR, by the way.
Thank you.
Wait, hold on.
Let me put my fucking tracker over.
God, this is so scoffed.
You think I'm gonna...
And this is why we don't listen to live.
You aren't really high volumes.
Have you learned your lesson?
Hold on.
This couldn't have gone any worse.
I am so sorry.
Hi.
I'm Strony.
Okay, I'm in the frame.
I'm in the frame.
First thing achieved.
Next thing I need to achieve for the 1530
is a celebration.
ilot
Did you get a walk now?
Can you hear it?
I'm sorry. I don't think I was wrong. Thank you for $55,000 subscribers. I know this is
This is why it's very hard to record for you someone. Look, I've still got income with fingers.
I've still got the manicure and pedicure.
Oh, it's a good name. Okay, thank you for this.
Can you start? Have I broken it?
Will you ever do a pan reveal? What do you want a pan reveal for?
I mean, I guess. Why would you want a pan reveal? What's so important?
Are you not wearing headphones? It's the morning. There's too many cables.
It's an absolute nightmare to do a webcam stream because there's extra cables introduced that will overlap correctly.
Have you not heard about Inky Pan before? Wait, have I just been debated at this time for the first time in a while?
Hand Arrows? Have you just opened me up to something I don't know about?
Wait, what's this Hand Arrows?
Girl, explain it to me. Sorry if you think you're kidding me.
Maybe I'll just open them.
My little leg. I don't even see anything.
My little leg is shaking.
I mean, I can do it.
What's that?
Some people like hands a lot.
What? I thought it was friends.
I literally thought it was friends.
I can wear this thing and I'm in a rental.
I wish you could see this thing on the floor. Yeah, this is an rental.
I can literally levitate here with your workers.
I don't think I've heard hands very much.
When you've got a carpet and a gaming chair.
I think there's so much effort to give you a lift to the nowhere.
For free?
Yes, for free.
You can do lots of things with a model.
You want to spend exorbitant amounts of money on a VTuber model.
That's right, I'm a crittin' life.
Sorry, my leg is just absolutely...
Unless, maybe I could turn the light on.
I don't know.
Oh, I can turn the light on.
Oh, I don't know.
If I had the money, I would have picked your anime girl.
I said everyone everywhere.
Hold up, I can turn the light on.
Oh, no, you're missing my gaming chair.
Can you see?
I can't get it out.
I'll wait inside.
Oh, that's not it.
No.
You can get sunset coffee.
We can't hear you, my mate.
Okay, I just need to stop the other thing.
Just enjoy the ear sore.
I don't get it.
You heard it.
Alright.
Okay.
Okay, there we go.
I can whisper now.
And I'm smart enough to know to whisper
when my long cup in the ears.
Now, did we have a few missed calls?
No.
Okay.
Why is this bowl broken?
You don't even have any money for it.
This is how long the microphone is.
Wait an inches.
Wait.
Oh, no, this is centimeters.
Okay.
Excuse me.
This is blissfully marvelous.
Thank you.
Okay, let's see.
If we get the microphone.
I forgot the ear sore.
The length of the microphone ear
is six and a half centimeters.
Now, I don't have long inches.
Okay.
So you're just going to have to show me tonight.
Don't have to do all of this.
Here, I'm going to touch it.
So you're quiet.
You have to be so gentle
when the ear falls.
The place that you do is once in here.
Don't touch me there.
She's touching my brain.
I'm always breaking inches.
Okay.
Yeah, my freaking pedicure
is still on my fingers.
And it won't come off.
A little.
I am so sorry
by the way
if you can hear the magpie
that's outside my window right now.
For some reason
I have an emphatic magpie
and
all it does
is sing inside the window
for cashier notes.
It's four a.m.
It's pitch black outside
and it's currently singing
for cashier notes.
Okay.
Since you have our pillar handy
Okay, so all cashiers
have their notes right behind
and just right behind them.
So we can break it next week.
Okay.
Okay, time to squish you.
Please squish you, Dave.
Okay.
Would you like some thigh pads?
I can't take this to me.
Meow, meow, meow, meow, meow.
Yeah.
My thank yous are ready
to subscribe.
I may not fall asleep
for 12 hours yesterday.
Sorry, big mistake.
Bad cash.
Okay.
I'm going to lower the volume
so you can see how much I can crush the microphone.
Okay.
I can't press my hand.
Take it.
Okay.
Thank you for the support
for the gifted membership.
I can't believe I'm so much more resilient.
You're so beautiful.
Thanks.
I'm really sure.
It will be wonderful!
Actually, everyone Capitol
has reached about these
career services and featured work.
You've been so long as I wonder
if I'm gonna hold it.
So we have 4 of us on a tag.
Okay, I'm just gonna meet
them when I get school.
Yeah.
I don't know, I don't know
I just really hardly bounce
and so
I want to
I want to do one more thing
I want to do it
I just want to
explore
who?
I need you to take your hands off of me
what?
I'm sorry
I feel like I'm supposed to do exactly that
Thank you, Archie, and cause I don't know if any of you can even understand me
I'm afraid that I can still hear you a little bit
Do that kind of thing, Archie
I feel like I'm supposed to do exactly that
I'm trying to get that
I feel a little touchy just between your ears
I feel like I'm pulling my hair
It's going to squeeze me
You want to be squeezing harder
You should know it's going to be easier
I'm just very dull
I don't want the tongue
I'll breathe it to the thigh
Does it feel like this side?
Is that a good sound?
I can't hear it
It's spectacular
Do it close to the ear
This is close to the ear
without blocking the sound
I so like it
Don't want to leave your other ear
My earjobs are going to bend
Cut down, eh?
I can't hear it
Okay, now write my thighs
What do you think?
Write them on a scale of cuteness
out of 10, right now
of Kawaii name
If maybe if they were skinny or they'd be cure
I can't go down too much because I'm wearing a thong
and nothing
Okay, cuteness for 10
Okay, what about strength?
What do we think on the budge scale?
Come on, you can't have thighs without a little budge
How do you think I go?
This beach, okay?
The cuteness of a kitty
The strength of a lion
Thank you for the super chat
and half of love
Budge, perfect
Oh yeah, you like it
And then on the end say there's budge as well
You budge on both sides
Okay
I just have to make sure you enjoy
Okay, now time to squeeze
the absolute crap out of you again
Thank you all for becoming a member
and rockstar
Would you say thank you for the meal?
Okay, time to squeeze
Why not?
What's going on?
Okay
Okay, we didn't need that many
Let me do it in my life
I'm sorry
I can't feel my legs
Okay
I feel the chair to be my face
Thank you in the whole bed
Wait, can you hear this?
Like that
That's what you should be saying
Okay
Do like this
Maybe three
Maybe two
And this is the other one
Okay
Then grippers
Put them grippers on
Okay, Mrs. Spiky
We already did
Okay
I don't have this fucking chair
No, maybe I should pick this one again
Hold on, I've got it
It's because I'm wearing tights
It's not like this
Okay, I can pick it up
I can do it
Shit
Okay
It's because I'm wearing tights
Okay, just ignore the fucking chair
Squeaking and everything
I can't
Rip the leggings
I managed to
If I can get my
I'm gonna wedge my toe in between
I swear you're the grippers
It's because I'm wearing tights
There's no grip anymore
The sweat is being taped
Okay
I'm scared with my toes
Okay, you have to believe
Just trust me bro
Again, you didn't hear the squeak
You get the massive chair
I'm glad you enjoyed it
Yeah, crimson, ti crimson
I'm gonna do any tactic
Where I put my thigh butch on the ear
Okay
It goes by the time
Thanks for the love
Over to the next time
Okay
It's working
Thank you
Unless you want to get my arms in the glass
Oh yeah
Okay
I just like
I don't know if that's gonna work
Or if I'm just gonna get in the way
Next up there
Thank you everybody
For the bye bye yeah
Thank you
I don't know if it's working
Or maybe I have more
Okay
I'm gonna work
Be careful
I borrowed these from A.C.
Thanks
Okay
I'm gonna touch them in general
I don't know if it's going to work
Okay
Squeeze me and pat my head
Let's go to the bar
Okay
I'll cut him far.
doesn't really matter
I want to make my ears smart
Okay, you hold my heart, okay?
I can give you a heart beat, easy, easy, no, excuse me.
Hold on, I'm procrastinating.
This is why it's my sweaty hand.
Okay, where's my heart?
Oh my god, my galaxy.
I can hear it.
I don't know if you hear it at all.
Do you hear the drumstick? No, it's from my
heart.
Oh my god.
I'm just doing my job.
Please flex guys, I don't know why I have to do that.
That's why you flex again, but because you don't have any muscles.
Open up.
I'm just doing my job.
I'm just having to lie back very awkwardly for that.
These are my calves, so they don't really get in my thighs.
I'm just doing my job.
Okay, now the chunk, because my thighs are underneath, so now they're extra juicy, because my chunk.
Oh, this doesn't look as good though.
It doesn't look as good.
Okay, we're experimenting. This is the first time we've done something like this, so we can't get it right all the time.
Ignore the cardboard that's on my floor, that's for my PC, because my PC sits on the cardboard.
Don't open the carpet, because you can't open your PC directly on the carpet.
Thank you Grimson, for his support.
Thank you, we've assigned it with this wonderful iPad, we're just swaying around.
Big squish.
Okay.